Let's talk now briefly about Dr. Anthony Foushee.
Dr. Fouche, she has finally had enough and is now
straight up saying the Trump campaign is harassing
me and hell, no, I'm not going to quit my job.
Remember that Dr. Foushee is the top infectious
disease doctor in the U.S. He's been increasingly
sidelined and ignored by the Trump campaign.
He was pulled out of the public eye after
being in it early in the pandemic. He was
blocked from doing TV interviews by the
Trump administration. And what looks to
be the last straw for him is that he was taken
out of context and used in a Trump campaign ad
in a way that sort of makes it look like Foushee
is endorsing Trump when it was actually completely
out of context. Foushee asked about this
while on CNN over the weekend. Take a look.
I do have to ask you about this Trump campaign
advertising where you're on camera saying, quote,
I can't imagine that anybody could be doing more.
You quickly came out with a statement that noted
that that sentence had been taken out of
context. You were talking about the whole
of government response, not President Trump. And
of course, you've never endorsed a presidential
candidate in your five decades of public service.
Should the Trump campaign take this ad down?
You know, I think so, Jake, I think it's really
unfortunate and really disappointing that they did
that. It's so clear that I'm not a political
person and I have never either directly or
indirectly endorsed a political candidate. And to
take it completely out of context statement and
put it in. Which is obviously a political campaign
ad I thought was really very disappointing.
What would you say if I told you I heard
that the Trump campaign was actually
preparing to do another ad featuring you?
You know, that would be terrible. I mean,
that would be outrageous if they do that. In fact,
that might actually come back to backfire on them.
I hope they don't do that because that's that
would be kind of playing a game that we don't
want to play. So I hope they reconsider that if,
in fact, they are indeed considering doing that.
I hope that they reconsider and not do that.
That mention of it might backfire is
something that has raised questions as to
whether Foushee is threatening to quit when
Foushee says this might backfire. There were
questions. Are you threatening to quit? And he
has said very clearly he is not threatening
to quit. After that interview, Foushee was
interviewed by The Daily Beast and asked if he's
considering quitting. He said, not a chance.
Not in my wildest freakin dreams did I ever
think about quitting. But he did go on to say
that, quote, By doing this against my will,
they are, in effect, harassing me. Look at
how backwards this country is. Dr. Foushee, who
is trying to save people and keep people alive,
ended up needing full time security thanks to
harassment from trumpet's Dr. Fouche. His family,
including his daughters, required security because
they were being threatened. And Foushee is a
public health expert. He's being forced to babysit
a toddler instead of save lives and to defend his
family from attacks with security. How can we be
forgiven for this? Constantly scapegoated, taken
out of context, denounced, ignored and pushed
aside now for months. And all because in his
narcissistic mind, Donald Trump thinks he's the
only one who can fix things. And unfortunately,
many of Trump's sycophantic followers agree.
When Trump said, well, you know, scientists,
I know more than the scientists. Many of
his followers cheered that they went right
along with it. And one of the things I most look
forward to about Joe Biden winning, if he wins,
is Dr. Foushee being treated the way he deserves
to be treated. Coming back to the forefront
of speaking to the country in an official
capacity about how to manage the pandemic,
it would be nice to see Foushee allowed to do
what he should be doing, what others in Fouche,
his position in other countries are being allowed
to do. And you know, these taking Foushee out
of context for a campaign ad is the lowest of
the low and it, quite frankly, isn't working.
Remember that Dr. Foushee is far more trusted
than Trump on the virus. They've been trying
to smear Foushee for months. And I guess you
could say, well, that the delta between Trump's
trustworthiness on the virus and fout cheese might
be even bigger were it not for the smear campaign.
But the last numbers we have from from last month,
68 percent of Americans say they trust Foushee
on the virus. 40 percent say they trust Trump.
Now, that's depressing because how how the hell
does 40 percent of the country trust Trump on the
virus? But at least, Fouche, his trustworthiness
is almost twice what Trump's is. But something
is very wrong here. When Trump says, I know more
than scientists and people cheer and 40 percent
of the country still trusts Trump on the virus,
we'll have more coverage of the out of context
use of Foushee video by the Trump campaign
on the show's Instagram page to make sure
you're following us there at David Pakman.